bonsoir nouveau numéro du 7-8 politique
sur tv 78 comme chaque mardi
l'actualité des élections municipales
des 15 et 22 mars prochain et pour cette
émission elle je reçois anne-claire
frémont bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
candidate aux clayes-sous-bois tête de
liste de les clayes-sous-bois c'est vous
une candidature sans étiquette qui a
reçu le soutien de la république en
marché du parti animalistes ainsi que de
la maire sortante d'éclat souvent on va
en parler dans un instant et vous êtes
depuis deux mandats maintenant adjointe
à l'éducation pourquoi vous lancer cette
fois ci comme tête de liste pourquoi
être vouloir devenir mère des clayes
sous bois mais dénigrer la première
chose parce que madame le maire sortante
ne se représente pas parce que sinon je
ne serais pas là aujourd'hui parce que
elle m'a demandé d'y penser il ya il ya
quelques temps et après mûre réflexion
il y en avoir parlé avec mon mari et mes
enfants parce que c'est un engagement
qu'on ne peut pas prendre si la famille
ne sut pas parce que si voilà
personnellement ça a un impact mais
également parce que parce que je connais
ma ville parce que j'y travaille depuis
35 ans je suis sapeur pompier
professionnel
je connais tous les quartiers je connais
les conditions de vie des lesbiennes et
des clés siens je connais leurs attentes
et pour toutes ces raisons en effet et
je me présente aujourd'hui avec beaucoup
d'envié mais également beaucoup
d'humilité nous c'est à dire vous allez
vous appuyez sur cette expérience
alors dans la ville des clayes sous bois
mais aussi en tant que quatre jantes à
l'éducation ces dossiers là vont vous
servir pour être pourquoi pas la fio tué
la fille sur mer ce mec-là sous bois
bien sûr bien sûr mon expérience de deux
mandats en tant que adjointe au maire à
l'éducation en france une délégation de
terrain ou en effet il faut donner les
meilleures conditions
à nos enfants de grandir d'apprentissage
et c'était une des priorités de madame
le maire sur ses trois mandats avec du
partenariat avec l'éducation nationale
les parents d'élèves
donc on apprend c'est un côté je
connaissais un peu moins de faire mon
métier mais on apprend on apprend
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de choses et
je vous dis vraiment j'ai beau j'ai
beaucoup d'envié
alors vous avez reçu le soutien de la
maire sortante eu des véronique côté
millard on l'a dit elle est élue depuis
2001 ne se représentera pas pour des
raisons qu'elle a déjà communiqué c'est
une fierté d'avoir son soutien ça revêt
aussi une importance pour vous une
responsabilité pour vous bien sûr que
c'est une fierté parce qu'en effet un
maire qui ne se représente pas doit
normalement trouver dans la liste
majoritaire la meilleure personne
qu'elle pense pouvoir prendre la suite
c'est une fierté que qu'elle met choisi
je pense en avoir les valeurs les
compétences
et oui sa vie dont vous assumez
aujourd'hui totalement le bilan de la
majorité sortante à laquelle vous
appartenez bien sûr j'assume totalement
le bilan déjà des demandes à où j'étais
présente mais mais l'héritage des trois
mandats de madame côté millar qui a fait
pour notre ville de très très belles
choses et a laissé une belle empreinte
alors c'est une majorité qui est partira
tout de même divisée philippe big n qui
est l'actuel premier adjoint de la
commune est aussi candidat dans une
autre liste vous regrettez qui est cette
division au sein de la majorité que les
siennes c'est comme ça le choix du maire
n'a pas été accepté par tout le monde
nous sommes en france en démocratie vous
pouvez vous ne pouvez empêcher personne
de se présenter aujourd'hui alors votre
liste qui est d'ailleurs complètement je
le précise
elle intégrera elle intègre des membres
de la majorité actuelle mais aussi de
nouveaux visages
oui bien sûr c'était l'objectif je
repars avec nous sommes dix membres de
la majorité actuelle dont les délégués à
l'enfance à la jeunesse aux loisirs
animation à la sécurité et à la vie
économique vie des quartiers donc des
délégations importantes qui feront le
socle de le socle de l'équipe mais j'ai
également voulu une équipe rajeunie
redynamiser avec des personnes de tous
les quartiers de sensibilité différente
de
de toutes les petites les générations et
surtout des personnes il n'y a pas de
hasard qui était déjà très impliqués
dans leur ville qui est qu'ils n'ont
envie que de servir l'intérêt général de
la ville et je reprécise 1 que même si
vous avez le soutien de la république en
marché du parti animalistes est une
liste bien sans étiquette pour ce
scrutin
parlons de votre campagne de votre
programme plus de 250 d'idées ont émergé
pour cette campagne aux clayes sous bois
avec des axes prioritaires forcément
notamment celui de l'environnement le
maire se doit d'agir en matière
d'environnement la mairie doit montrer
l'exemple en matière d'environnement
oui le dernier mandat comme quand nous
nous sommes présentés et l'environnement
étaient réservées aux parties avaient
écologique et c'est tout aujourd'hui
liste qui ne parlent pas environnement
n'a rien compris du tout le monde se
saisit de l'environnement va être un des
gros enjeux des six années à venir
tout le monde est prêt en effet à faire
enfin quelque chose pour pour notre
planète pour l'héritage que nous allons
oser laisser à nos enfants et nous nous
souhaitons vraiment mettre un point sur
les actions locales
parce qu'il faut que ça parle à tout le
monde actions locales il faut
sensibiliser et changer nos habitudes
changer nos automatismes
alors un 20 ans c'est pas difficile à
nos âges ça va être un petit peu compte
plus compliqué mais nous y croyons
fortement et il faut il va falloir
favoriser les actions citoyennes les
actions associatives qui fonctionne de
mieux en mieux aujourd'hui
promouvoir la mobilité douce notamment
c'est que les clayes-sous-bois est une
commune concernée par une circulation
dense donc c'est aussi important de de
promouvoir une circulation et des
mobilités douces
bien sûr ça fait partie ça fait partie
des actions que nous allons mettre en
place pour l'environnement favoriser le
vélo favoriser les transports en commun
favoriser le véhicule électrique qui
aujourd'hui est le véhicule le plus
propre que l'on que l'on peut avoir est
donc d'autres priorités il ya une autre
priorité pour les clés siens et les clés
s'il etc les siennes et les clés science
et le vivre ensemble
c'est l'un des autres axes majoritaire
de
de votre campagne quelles propositions
en la matière de vivre ensemble oui le
vivre ensemble parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte du en effet les trois mandats
n'dam côté minarets là elle a beaucoup
transformé la ville en bien et ce qui
remonte en effet nos réflexions et des
interrogations
c'est une forte demande de réapprendre à
vivre ensemble
arrêter de vivre les uns à côté des
autres et recommencer à vivre les uns
avec les autres et c'est un des gros axe
et le vivre ensemble nous le retrouvons
également dans toutes les thématiques de
notre programme et ça va passer en effet
par des actions des animations la mise
en place d'un conseil de ville
intergénérationnel avec un budget
participatif en matière de santé autre
axe important la commune fait face à une
diminution de son nombre de médecins et
quels sont les leviers qu'on peut
activer pour faire face à cette pénurie
peut-être qu'ils approchent pourquoi
comment comment on évite la pénurie
justement en moi je dirais que c'est pas
que le nombre de médecins en plus nous
avons des médecins qui vont partir en
retraite dans les années à venir et ça
va devenir problématique mais surtout
c'est surtout le paramédical nous
n'avons plus qu'un kiné aux
clayes-sous-bois et nous avons comme
comme acte de connexion
lemaitre déjà en place un conseil de
santé parce que qui mieux que les
professionnels de santé
dès que les sous-bois savent ce dont a
besoin la ville ce dont ont besoin les
habitants donc nous allons avec eux
mettre en place un cahier des charges
qui va on l'espère favoriser
l'implantation d'une maison
pluridisciplinaire et surtout faire en
sorte qu'elle se remplisse et en
partenariat bien évidemment avec l'
agence régionale de la santé avec qui
sentit on ne fait rien pour terminer sur
vos axes prioritaires y en a aussi en
matière de culture il ya des projets en
matière de culture que vous voulez
porter aux clayes-sous-bois oui oui nous
avait un ce qu'on appelle le projet
tutti passeur d'art qui est sur trois
ans qui est basé sur trois ans qui sera
en partenariat certainement avec
l'éducation nationale c'est à dire que
pendant trois ans aucun on confie un
appareil de musique un enfant on lui
donne la possibilité gratuitement de
prendre entre quatre et six heures de
cours par par semaine et on monte un
orchestre municipal après qui va
intervenir petit à petit dans toutes les
dents toutes les animations de la ville
ou autre ça s'est fait dans beaucoup de
villes
c'est très riche et voilà ça n'exclut
personne puisque ce sera pour une
tranche d'âge pendant trois ans et en
parallèle nous souhaitons parce que nous
ne voulons pas qu'au bout de trois ans
ce projet s'arrête donc en partenariat
avec les associations nous souhaitons
que cette cet orchestre devienne un
orchestre inter générationnelle
est porté par les associations et la
municipalité
alors voilà pour vos propositions une
dernière chose vos prochains rendez vous
de campagne quand allez-vous rencontrer
prochainement les clés siens prochain
rendez vous de campagne le 26 février à
l'école élémentaire aurait prou à 20
heures merci avec l'air frémont je
rappelle que vous êtes la tête de liste
des clayes-sous-bois c'est vous une
candidature sans étiquette soutenu par
la république en marche le parti
animalistes et la maire sortante des
clayes sous bois et véronique côté
millard sont également candidats je le
rappelle pour le scrutin le premier
adjoint philippe guillen élu
d'opposition à nicolas eu ainsi que
stéphanie jamin merci d'avoir été avec
nous à guyancourt olivier par les ja et
la tête de liste de décidons ensemble à
guyancourt il poursuit sa campagne
l'ancien élu de la majorité présente une
candidature sans étiquette et
participative
reportage lors d'une opération
porte-à-porte avec mélanie poké et
marylène yapi celle bonsoir c'est pour
les élections municipales on vient vous
présenter notre liston depuis début
janvier deux à trois fois par semaine
l'équipe de décidons ensemble à
guyancourt toc aux portes des habitants
de la commune
la liste menée par olivier paréja
présente un programme construit lors
d'ateliers la participation l'un des
trois grands axes développés mal l'idée
c'est que y ait un certain nombre de
commissions qu'ils soient ouvertes aux
habitants
ce sera complètement transparent et si
les gens sur un sujet précis qui les
intéressent ont envie de donner leur
avis ont envie de construire un projet à
ce moment là ils seront les bienvenus
on salue on fera des commissions
ok j'évaluerai si les étrangers la
solidarité et l'écologie sont les deux
autres piliers du programme ce qui a
particulièrement séduit noémie audouze
impliqué dans la vie associative elle
saute le pas de l'engagement politique
pour la première fois il ya une urgence
climatique dont on parle vraiment
partout et là il faut vraiment en
prendre conscience
chacun peut faire sa part chez lui au
niveau individuel au niveau de sa
consommation de sa mobilité de plein de
choses
les mairies aussi ont un grand pouvoir
de
d'agir sur beaucoup de levier énormément
d'investissement qui sont décidés par
les collectivités locales que ce soit de
l'aménagement que ça soit du transport
que ce soit des espaces verts que ce
soit la protection des étangs de la
minière toutes ces choses là sont quand
même des choses qui sont à la main des
collectivités locales décidons ensemble
à guyancourt poursuit ses rencontres
avec les guyancourt toi prochaine
réunion publique le 29 février à la
maison de quartier cosma quatre autres
livres se sont déclarés dans cette
commune coup d'oeil à présent sur
quelques rendez vous de campagne des
candidats aux municipales à commencer
par la ville des mureaux avec une
réunion publique hier hervé riou ce
mercredi 19 février à 19 heures à
l'espace des habitants il est à la tête
de la liste les mureaux pour tous une
candidature divers droite hervé riou qui
fait face au maire sortant françois
garay à agnetz s'étendent à ainsi qu'à
nicolas bré dessous aversa ils seront
huit candidats pour le scrutin notamment
renault en dieu qui conduit vivre versa
une liste sans étiquette
elle organise ce mercredi 19 février à
19h30 une rencontre topware un moment
ait des changes pour partager les idées
un rendez vous chez l'habitant dans le
quartier montreuil chantier pour
connaître l'adresse il faut s'inscrire
ce jeudi 20 février à 20 heures réunion
publique donnée à l'agora
mantes-la-jolie rendez vous de campagne
et de raphaël cognait maire sortant il
est élu depuis 2017 et conduire à man tu
n'y es deux autres candidats dans la
ville du nord des yvelines david
stefanelli et marc jammet enfin à
rambouillet ce sera un duel à 5 pour ces
élections municipales dont le premier
tour est le 15 mars prochain véronique
mathieu et la tête de liste de
rambouillet ensemble vers l'avenir
candidate de la majorité pour prendre la
suite de marc robert une réunion
publique est prévue ce lundi 24 février
7 à 20 heures au théâtre le nickel avant
de vous laisser ce rendez vous et aidez
78 radio sensations vous propose un
nouveau week-end spécial élections
municipales samedi et dimanche prochain
ce seront neufs débats qui seront à
retrouver en direct sur notre chaîne et
sur la fréquence 98 points 4 fm et des
émissions à revoir en rediffusion toute
la semaine prochaine également en replay
sur tv 78 points comme ainsi qu en
podcast audio / sensation yvelines
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro du 7-8
politique l'actualité des élections
municipales à retrouver également sur
notre application mobile belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]